hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video wehrleute ich
befinde mich dass ich mir spontan gstaad
das video einfach mal von hier und zwar
steht heute an geld experiment part 3
startet die gespannt ich hoffe es wird
ja ich habe mir was cooles also ich hab
es mir nicht selber überlegt ist halt
einfach so gelaufen ich muss euch ganz
kurz das zeigen konnte schon aktuell
letztmalig 3300 irgendwas am ende davon
sind leider aktuell nur noch 460 euro 97
über ihr fragt euch jetzt sicherlich
alex was hast du gemacht ich habe eine
mail bekommen von einem media-markt
sales manager mannes so nennt ich darf
leider seinen namen oder den media markt
nicht nennen aber wir schauen uns die
männer an es wird zensiert und dann
erkläre ich euch den rest weg aber es
wird cool und ich glaube das teuerste
was ich hier gekauft habe ach so leute
in diesem 460 euro irgendwas von gerade
sind auch hier von dem video noch die
183 schon enthalten hat habe ich mit dem
netz - verdienen das wollte ich noch
gesagt haben ist ganz wichtig jetzt
passt auf ich habe eine e mail wir
müssen uns kurz hier überwachen weil am
gaming pc hab ich hier keinen zugriff
auf die mails ich versuche es euch
bestmögliche 1 plänen und zwar hat mir
der perlen geschrieben hallo herr müller
also ich heiße danach noch nicht herr
müller nur wenn man mich googelt oder
auf wikipedia steht irgendwie das ich
mit nach einer müller heiße keine ahnung
wie das zustande kamen aber gut
wahrscheinlich hat derjenige das
geschrieben hat einfach gesagt ach ja
müller heißt ja die meisten deutschland
der wahrscheinlich auch kommen hier marc
schreiber müller nach infos von einem
unserer kollegen sind wir informiert
worden dass ist gegebenfalls interesse
an einer mehrere mystery boxen gibt um
ein projekt weiterführen zu können dann
habe ich geschrieben vielen dank für
ihre nachricht genau aktuell gibt es ein
projekt für das sich weitere pakete gut
gebrauchen kann dann hat er geschrieben
das können wir realisieren mindestens
6000 euro warenwert für 3000 euro dazu
dann noch beschrieben wichtig für uns
wäre lediglich die nichterfüllung
unseres standortes auf jeden fall hatte
eine denke ich etwas höhere position in
der media markt ich fand das ganz
interessant weil man konnte auch nie
über ebay teure mediamarkt boxen kaufen
und ich habe die hoffnung in den händen
dass er mich so porten will mit dem
youtube projekt was ich hier mache und
deswegen gute sachen rein tut und ich
hoffe halt auf guten gewinnen so genau
soviel erstmal dazu ich würde sagen
zurück ins büro wir packen den ganzen
schritt mal aus wenn ich leute drückt
mir die daumen und leute wenn ihr das
projekt cool findet dann abonniert super
super gerne den kanal weil die meisten
videos schauen haben es irgendwie nicht
gemacht würde ich mich mehr darüber
freuen weil dann verpasst ihr die
nächsten folgen nicht und jetzt geht es
weiter leute das geht ganz kurz nur ich
wollte eigentlich gerade oder ich habe
kurz das damals gemacht damit ich das
immer fertig ab und wollte die sache
morgen auspacken wir haben jetzt schon
19 uhr und ich wollte jetzt halt noch zu
meinem kumpel das ding ist nur ich bin
so neugierig ich mache jetzt zwei auf es
muss sein ihr habt ja alles erfahren zu
den dingern ich glaube hier in diesem
schwarzen paket ist nur eine sache drin
deswegen starten wir damit mal
vielleicht ist das so dyson könnte ich
mir vorstellen
ich hoffe wirklich dass der typ der mir
das angebot gemacht hat nicht zu viel
versprochen hat und dass sich das für
mich ordentlich lohnen wird wir werden
sehen
das ist schon mal kein leisten aber ich
glaube es ist ein staubsauger und es
sieht nach einem hochwertigen
staubsauger aus wie ist eingepackten hat
nach ja die ganze originalverpackung
kaputt
komm schon okay hier haben wir ein
rowenta x-force flex guck mal leute so
sieht das ging aus dass einfach ein bild
logo drauf wieso das denn hat bei bild
jetzt als bild edition ach du scheiße
ist das denn also ich habe gedacht er
ist mehrwert kostet leider nur 211 euro
ich kann sagen dieses paket ist nicht so
schwer diese beiden sind extrem schwer
und das wird so als wären in diesem
paket extrem viele sachen deswegen
machen wir doch dass hier auf und dann
reicht's aber die leute dann gehe ich in
meinen wohlverdienten feierabend okay
sagt sag dann gibt mir etwas gutes man
also unter 1800 euro ausbeute aus den
ersten beiden paketen verlasse ich den
raum heute nicht ich bin wirklich nervös
eine leute ohne scheiß bin so nervös das
ist ja wieder rowenta auch hier stehen
die ganzen sachen das regenwasser zur
seite damit der überraschungs will
einfach viel zu neugierig für diese
sachen hier haben wir jetzt einen
leistungsstarken
ventilator perfekt also dabei sich auch
so sieht er aus da weiß ich auch der
wird auf jeden fall nicht mehr als 200
euro kosten denkmal wie googles kurz was
ist dieses rowenta ich habe das noch nie
gehört kommt dafür sonne peter karton
der kostet auf amazon einfach 24 euro
habe man das startete überhaupt nicht
gut kann doch nicht sein oder wir haben
jetzt wirklich aus dem ersten neuen
paketen nur 234 euro sozusagen also ich
hätte niemals gedacht dass dieser
ventilator nur 25 euro kostet ohne
scheiß dann welchen auf jeden fall hier
in meinem büro behalten weil ich habe
keinen und es lohnt sich gar nicht
weiterzuverkaufen okay kommt ich kann
nicht aufhören wir machen das nächste
paket jetzt auch noch auf man hier muss
jetzt wirklich einiges drin sein sonst
sonst wenig wirst du hast also alles
unter 6000 euro warenwert
was auch nur eine sache rasenmäher
rasenmäher das kann doch nicht sein okay
das war der schwer
ich haben wir einen rasenmäher von
welchen marke ist und dass android na
also das ist wirklich eine sache reddot
design award 100 2017 mit rasen robotern
kenne ich mich überhaupt nicht aus hatte
ich noch nie berührung zu außer jetzt
halt ich hab es berührt der kostet
einfach auch nur 286 euro ich habe 3000
euro bezahlt dafür und wir sind jetzt
gerade bei 500 das kann doch nicht sein
dass in diesem paket jetzt
5500 euro drin sind oder wie es wird
schon mal kurz die location das ding ist
jetzt einfach ich muss das letzte paket
auch noch auf machen weil ich weiß ganz
genau ich kann sonst heute nicht
schlafen wenn ich diese 500 euro im kopf
habe und weiß nicht dafür drei
mittäter zu dem paket habe ich auch
schon gesagt ich glaube hier ist viel
drin ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie
ich mich gerade fühle leute ohne wird es
ist wie als ich meine alles
entscheidende klausur wieder bekommen
habe vom abi oder mein notendurchschnitt
hat es noch schlimmer gerade ansicht der
kann ja auch nicht einfach mir nur so
1000 euro dar einpacken wenn ich den
3000 euro bezahlt hat
wir haben hier das dti ronin es das ist
auf jeden fall extrem beliebt das weiß
ich hab mir selber so eines wie heißen
die dafür hätte man das denn nochmal
genau das ist ein gebilde sind bei video
graphen auf jeden fall extrem beliebt
die drei dinger supercool mir fast
sicher dass das um die 1000 euro kostet
wenn nicht sogar mehr ich weiß es gerade
nicht ganz klar ob das das neueste ist
aber die haben auf jeden fall ein extrem
hohen wert ihr seht ihr jetzt hier
einwände dann haben wir als nächstes
einen taschenrechner cyberjack von
chipkartenleser ist doch kein
taschenrechner das sind an gerät für
online-banking okay so hier ist wirklich
jede menge drin dann haben wir hier in
objektiven canon objektiv welches ist
das 75 300 millimeter komplett frisch
verpackt ich will das eigentlich auch
gar nicht aufmachen weil sonst mac hat
wieder irgendjemand so sieht das auf
jeden fall aus ich muss abdecken wie
viel man dafür nehmen kann ich denke mal
da um die 500 euro dann haben wir noch
mehr kamera equipment da ist ein huawei
partei
was da kostet nur der pencils ich nehme
euch mal kurz leute ist es ja auf der
einen seite gut dass wir wirklich nicht
so viele produkte haben er hätte daher
auch 50 sachen rein tun könnt man muss
halt erstmal auf diese mindestens sechs
euro ich habe gehofft dass hier
vielleicht auch 8000 euro drin sind das
hat sich ja irgendwie so angehört
vielleicht kommen wir auch noch auf
diesen wert aber je weniger teure sachen
desto besser für mich natürlich weil die
kann ich schneller einzeln verkaufen so
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr am schwitzen
so sieht das aus ich würde euch hier mal
rein hier haben wir glaube ich noch was
ehre das sieht noch großen wert aus wir
machen wir mit dem label sachen weiter
haben wir einen wecker das sind halt
jetzt wirklich so sachen dabei ist du
das kauft kaum jemand haben wir
verschiedene cover zum beispiel für das
galaxy tab das ist von 2019 also das ist
immer so ein problem bei sowas der kauf
zu was noch ich habe immer das gefühl es
gibt viel viel mehr covers und hüllen
für so geräte als es überhaupt geräte
gibt es jetzt auf 32 eur 990 aber runter
geht es auf 15 euro das gleiche haben
wir hier untergeht auf 35 euro einfach
mehr gibt dann 70 euro für flüge aus
oder ist auch drin ist wer hat so okay
es ist mit keyboard er gut vielleicht
kriegt die zusammen verkauft da sind
noch mehr dabei 5 ich hoffe mal der
verkäufer hat den reduzierten preis
berechnet und nicht den ovp preis dann
haben
wir machen erstmal hier mit weiter von
canon ein licht die sind auch save gar
nicht mal so günstig kenne ich mich auch
nicht so ganz gut aus aber ich würde mal
250 euro sagen ordnen das direkt schon
mal kamera kamera ok weiter geht's mit
einem gut sehr nett danke für diesen
ventilator oder fehlen leider die
batterien gut leute da braucht man nicht
zu bereden den kann ich nicht verkaufen
hier haben wir noch ein cover das ist
halt schade
dann haben wir hier ist das noch ein
gimbel von raleigh auf 60 euro
heruntergesetzt
ich hatte ein bisschen angst heute kommt
man hier in der ecke schaut euch das mal
versteckt sich die canon eos sechs dem
markt 2 geil das ist gut ich glaube dass
es abschließend ganz cool für heute
diesen ausschnitt zu beenden jetzt kann
ich ruhig schlafen gehen und ich glaube
wir haben wirklich ich muss es morgen
mal ausrechnen wir haben extrem guten
warenwert über 6000 euro ist vorbei ich
kann sich genau sagen aber ich habe ein
gutes gefühl wir hatten jetzt so viele
kameras sachen da drin und die sind
natürlich meistens nicht günstig
deswegen leute wir sehen uns morgen
wieder bis gleich
die leute irgendwie glaube übrigens
schon jetzt zum nächsten tag ich habe
hier so einfliegen lässt das klingt voll
eklig aber irgendwie ihr sind manchmal
einfach fliegen auf dem boden und ich
frag mich wo kommt er her weil die
fenster sind halt immer zu
dann sag ich dir heute mal eine ich bin
da gestern nach hause gefahren hier sind
noch einige sachen drin hab ich euch
noch nicht gezeigt zumindest nicht im
detail deswegen starten wir hiermit die
haben wir zum beispiel noch eine bbl
xtreme 2 wir müssen auch irgendwo
zwischen 215 320 euro glaube ich kosten
dann haben wir hier gut das ist nichts
wert irgendwas von bose weiter geht's
mit orion stuhl usb das problem ist also
ich kenne mich mit so etwas gar nicht
aus vielleicht gibt es dann markt aber
das ding kostet 80 euro ich wüsste noch
nicht nämlich das verkaufen soll wird
aber schon irgendwie sich ergeben dann
haben wir hier noch so eine klingel wild
video doppel ass ok kannst du vor dein
haus hängen sondern sie ist immer wieder
klingelt die müsste irgendwie 150 euro
kosten dann kommt hier noch sonne makita
akku bohrmaschine dazu dann haben wir
hier noch eine makita random orbitz
immer wissen dass da kenne ich mich
leider überhaupt nicht mit aus absolut
eine sache die ich dann noch vergessen
habe hier haben wir den sony
fdx 53 das ist ein camcorder und sohn
keine ist auch noch drin aber die haben
ja keinen werten oder was heißt kein
glaube 40 euro kosten die aktuell der
camcorder ist aber auf jeden fall nicht
schlecht sieben monaten 990 euro auf der
günstigsten website
jetzt haben wir aber dann doch wirklich
jede menge sachen und die alle lust
werden das wird verdammt aufwendig ich
habe es heute morgen mal durchgerechnet
alles zusammen kostet neu
6200 euro wenn ich das weiterverkaufen
denke ich wenn es wirklich gut läuft
bekomme ich 5000 euro ich denke aber es
wird weniger ich schätze mal so 4700
aber dann hätte ich trotzdem den gewinn
von 1700 euro gemacht ich habe einige
sachen auch schon zum verkauf angeboten
wir werden die nächsten tage bisschen
analysieren ich gebe euch ein update mal
schauen wie lange es dauert und dann
hoffe ich dass ich den dritten part von
geld experiment mit über 5.000 euro
abschließen kann wir hatten leider noch
keinen kooperationspartner in diesen
videos uns wird es ein bisschen
schneller gehen aber moment mal leute
ich muss trotzdem dafür bekomme ich kein
geld ich war letztens auch im sony event
in berlin da wird unter anderem diese
neue m vorgestellt das ist so eine promi
camp mega meist sehr kompakt das ist die
z 14 wir können ja mal an machen hat
hier auch so ein streng display kann man
umdrehen sagt und ihr könnt direkt drauf
los sorgen also die kann ich wirklich
jedem empfehlen ich habe damit auch mein
letztes video gedreht die kamera bringt
einige neue coole features mit jack das
gerne ab danke auf jeden fall an sony an
dieser stelle wir sehen uns heute ist
übrigens der letzte tag musst du mal
waren das
destillat gerade mal installiert er wird
mich auf jeden fall ein bisschen öfter
begleiten wollte ich hatte mal gezeigt
haben weil sie halt nicht hin zu
verkaufen leute das geht ich habe euch
jetzt gut einige zeit ist vergangen um
genau zu sein glaube ich vier tage ich
habe echt jede menge zeit investiert die
ganzen sachen loszuwerden und ich bin
immer noch nicht fertig wir hatten so
ein rasenmäher und noch eine kamera habe
ich privat verkauft alles andere über
ebay und ich bin aber noch längst nicht
fertig da muss natürlich auch eric durch
sein dieses ding mir da gibt sich kein
warum auch immer also gut ich habe das
vorher noch nie gesehen und haben wir
noch ein paar sachen die habe ich auch
noch nicht verkauft die sind anscheinend
alle nicht so beliebt ich hoffe aber
einfach mal dass das noch was wird ihr
haben wir ein paket da habe ich so diese
ganzen krimskrams sachen reingepackt das
versuche ich auch noch für 350 euro
loszuwerden ich habe sogar für 400 drin
glaube ich aktuell bei dem wetter ab
wunderschönen ja das passt auf jeden
fall zu meinem verkäufen folge habe ich
nämlich noch gar nichts verkauft ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen wir haben zwar
jetzt über 4000 euro auf dem konto was
gut ist also wir konnten das noch mal um
600 euro übertreffen ich hab mir
allerdings viel viel mehr von diesem
projekt erhofft muss ich auch sagen weil
ich einfach dachte da sind noch bessere
sachen drin die man vielleicht noch
einfach aber kaufen kann aber dem war
wohl nicht so trotzdem werde ich
natürlich nicht aufgeben wir machen
weiter wenn ich die anderen sachen auch
loswerden wie werde ich los safe dann
sind wir vielleicht dann schon bei über
5.000 euro auch was gutes aber wir
müssen uns jetzt an rick steps rennwagen
weil ich habe noch ziemlich viel vor mir
25.000 euro fehlen auch ein monat ist
jetzt glaube ich schon vergangen also
ich weiß nicht ganz ich hoffe trotzdem
fand das interessant lass mir super
gerne doch nach oben da abonniert den
kanal und das was mir leute haut rein